do you agree with vegt Netanyahu that
there needs to be this kind of extreme
force in response well you know I think
they are a very small country surrounded
by countries that are really trying to
destroy them like have here just a
little thing from the Hamas there's a
whole series of television programs in
which they say to their chair kids there
is no such thing as Israel there is no
Israel can you see the map of Palestine
all of it will return to us let me just
take like a show okay so this is from
where you know just these are pictures
that are put out okay by the Palestinian
media watch now the only thing I'm
saying here is anybody who knows that
region knows that there is an
unrelenting attack on Israel in every
possible way whether it's a propaganda
whether it's public affairs whether its
military whether it's an intelligence
everything ok now but this this whole
thing changed ok once you had weaponry
that was rocketry ok with fortunately
the Israelis had this protective system
the Iron Dome in which they were able to
introduce these missiles that were being
sent but you can imagine if the United
States had Canada sending in these
missiles every day and mess with her on
the other what the response would be ok
well let me just hold this up for our
viewers so that so that just in case
they they this is some of what the what
is this called the Palestinian media
watch ok so uh Richard I want to bring
you in on this conversation so more you
know look through this and he says look
when you see this on on television in
you know that there's no such thing as
Israel there is no Israel according to
Hamas TV and the Israelis say that that
is a justification that they see 4444
basically defending themselves from from
this kind of attack what's your response
to this Richard well Israel like any
nation state obviously has the right for
the self-defense the problem with the
Israelis strategy it's really the
Israeli predicament is that it cannot
eliminate Hamas politically or
militarily through
through attacks no matter how severe the
attacks are and indeed to some extent it
actually could strengthen Hamas because
Hamas will survive even if it's weakened
and then it reinforces its its standing
as the only Palestinian group willing to
to stand up to Israel so i would say in
the short run the best strategy for
israel is to figure out a way of getting
what the prime minister called calm for
calm some sort of a ceasefire which
admittedly does not resolve the
situation but at least it it comes it
and then i do think the Israelis need to
reconsider their diplomatic or political
strategy and what they can do to
possibly split Hamas away from the more
moderate or less radical Palestinians
and see if they can't get serious about
negotiating a deal with those
Palestinians who essentially run the
West Bank I agree with that but having
being directly involved in this thing I
can say they've been trying to negotiate
with Hamas and anybody who sees what
Hamas does what kamat says not only to
the Israelis but to their own people is
which is which this is a illustration
Hamas is not prepared to do it they are
very worn no one no one is suggesting
here that Israel negotiate with Hamas my
whole point is that the Israelis need a
strategy from negotiating with those
Palestinians who at least have been
historically prepared to negotiate and
to accept Israel they've not been
historically prepared to make major
compromises for peace however but I do
think in fact I know and you know that
they have been trying to have these
negotiations and they have been
unsuccessful because in fact what's
happened is that there is an effect the
struggle between Hamas and the slightly
more moderate groups and the moderate
groups are afraid to be too moderate
because Hamas frankly appeals to the
fundamental views of a lot of the
Palestinians so it's a usually
complicated thing the Israelis have
tried through a God knows how many
administration's to how many years in
decades to develop this kind of peaceful
resolution it has not taken place in
part i might say it's going to take an
outside party for example the Americans
if they could properly handle themselves
which I don't believe they have to lead
the two of them together to a common
ground well Richard do you think the
Americans have the wherewithal to be
able to broker something well history
would suggest a little bit of modesty
here any number of Americans secretaries
of state and administrations have tried
I don't think in the particular
circumstances this situation is
particularly ripe for a diplomatic
breakthrough John Kerry tried a whole
lot that said it's the only real game in
town and I would say you need to
strengthen the Palestinians on the West
Bank economically one has to also build
them up more in the security sense and
then you've got to put something
generous on the table and I think that
is the only hope we have lest we find
ourselves every couple of years facing a
new Hamas led sort of Intifada but ever
but arms with ever more dangerous
systems as Israel is now facing